good morning Hank it's Tuesday so as of
tomorrow I will be one month into my
year without social media
I left reddit Instagram Facebook and
Twitter because I felt like I couldn't
effectively regulate the amount of time
I was spending on those platforms or the
experience I was having and also I was
looking at my phone hundreds of times
per day which just kind of freaked me
out so I decided to take a year off for
my computer I use a Chrome extension
called stay focused which has a
so-called nuclear option where you can
block access to certain websites
completely and then I use the screen
time app on my phone to disable Safari
and the App Store and I deleted all of
the like attention-grabbing apps now my
phone still does a lot of things it can
order food and hail rides and check-in
for flights and take high-resolution
video and predict the weather and also
it's a phone now that I think about it
it's basically a magic wand it's just a
magic wand that can't tell me how people
feel about Will Smith being in the
Aladdin movie how's it going so far
um okay the first thing I learned is
that without really being aware of it I
type the words Reddit and Twitter and
Facebook into a web browser like dozens
of times per day like I had noticed that
it had become harder to like lose myself
in a book for instance without feeling
an urge to check my phone or open my
computer
but I did not realize how fractured my
atention had become or how many times
per day I would answer the first hint of
boredom or stasis by going to read it a
month in I am happier or at least less
anxious one of the weird things about
social media for me is that it tends to
make me feel very itchy in a way that
only social media can scratch and
turning it off has mostly cured that
itch also I have more time I had time
for instance to write an art assignment
video about Agnes Martin which you can
check out in the doobly-doo and I have
more time with my family which is nice
another advantage is that I spend less
time looking at the news but I think I
might be better informed like I have a
much better idea for instance of what's
going on in Yemen than I did a month ago
also because I'm reading my hometown
newspaper I feel like I understand my
IRL community a little bit better
lastly I'm getting bored more often now
don't be wrong boredom is unpleasant but
if I can let myself be bored which is a
big if as I'll get to in a moment then I
find myself like having thoughts which
is really nice also those thoughts
because I can't share them on Twitter
are like mine
all that noted leaving the social
Internet hasn't been like the magical
experience I'd hoped for for one thing I
miss it more than I expected to I miss
reading funny reddit threads on soccer I
missed the feeling of camaraderie on
Twitter but the bigger issue and maybe I
should have seen this coming is that
simply eliminating certain social media
platforms from my life doesn't fix
anything
it doesn't unfractionated I at
inherently healthier because it turns
out there are lots of other websites
that are happy to feed without
nourishing and distract without
enriching not being able to get to like
any web sites on my phone has been
really good for me I think but I need
the internet on my computer and more to
the point the internet is not the
problem my internet is the problem and
the thing I've learned this month is
that for my internet to change I need to
change for the next 10 weeks over at
crash course I'm hosting a series on
navigating digital information it tries
to take an evidence-based approach to
evaluating the quality of the
information we encounter online and
spotting and dismissing misinformation
now I have sometimes believe that I'm
like immune to misinformation but I've
come to understand that such a belief
actually makes you more susceptible to
it and the tools I've learned through
working on this crash course have been
super helpful to me both in terms of how
I research online and in terms of what
kinds of information I ingest in fact I
think it's positively affected my
internet more than any particular web
site I've blocked so I really hope
you'll check it out that said I am gonna
stay off social media for the rest of
the year I don't know that I recommend
it in general but I think it is
necessary for me I need to discover more
of what lies on the other side of
boredom Hank I'll see you on Friday